you know between the fluidity and my
sense of self and my a DD I suspect that
my demon would never actually settle on
a form His Dark Materials or at least
the first four episodes of it this
wasn't something that I had intended to
watch I actually got commissioned to
watch it through patreon which is
something you can do actually it was a
funny thing because one patreon
supporter commissioned me to watch the
first two episodes and then another
commissioned me to watch another two
which is why I watched for now I went
into this thinking that okay I'll watch
the first four episodes and if I'm
really into it maybe I'll watch the rest
and give my thoughts on the whole thing
I didn't do that I stopped at the four
which should probably give at least an
overview impression of my thoughts on it
so here's the first thing that you need
to know because I actually think it
matters more here than it would normally
when it comes to my opinion and views on
a piece of work I don't know the
original I never read the books I
haven't even seen the previous
adaptation the film version of the
Golden Compass because I well I've seen
bits and pieces of it but it didn't look
that great and I just never got around
to the books I heard very mixed things
about them especially by the time that
it wrapped up and I was just like I'll
pass so I am coming at this as a person
with no foreknowledge of the world the
characters how it works the system of
society the stakes really anything I'm
coming in cold and I think that is the
key reason why I didn't enjoy it I don't
think this adaptation was made with
people who have zero familiarity with
the source material of mind it did very
little to meet me halfway it did not
feel like it was extending very many
olive branches to try and get me on
board now maybe the books are like that
too
I don't know I would think probably not
if for no other reason or at least not
to this degree and if for no other
reason than the fact that in the written
form you have the potential for
narrative exposition you don't have to
find a way to drop everything into
dialogue because through the narration
and just the way things are described a
lot of information can just be dropped
in the text straightforwardly and
obviously in a visual medium you lose
the ability to do that and so all I'm
left with is the contextual stuff and
for me to get my head wrapped around
this I needed a lot more straight-up
exposition then I got I'm not gonna say
I understood nothing but the number of
fundamental questions that I had about
how this world even works and who liked
the general standing of any of the
things going on beyond really broad
strokes that I didn't find engaging I
needed more information than this and
I'm sure the information exists and I'm
gonna say up front before I even start
getting into specific criticisms I'm
going to be asking a lot of questions
and saying a lot of things that I feel
were poorly explained or didn't make
sense and I know a ton of people in the
comments are gonna be leaving me details
month well it was this well it was this
this is what it means like I I'm not
asking cuz I actually wants you to
answer them I'm asking because four
episodes in I feel I shouldn't still be
asking this many fundamental questions
as I'm gonna be putting out there I'm
not saying there's no answers I'm saying
that four episodes in I don't have them
and I kind of don't care is a problem
that's the point I'm making so please
don't respond with comments answering
the things that I don't understand
because I'm already done with this
series I feel that it has failed to make
the effort to bring me as someone with
no foreknowledge into it and answering
the questions isn't something gonna make
me think this thing was any better than
I currently think it is okay okay
so I'll try and start positive because
it's
like it's a bad show it certainly is
well shot the the performances are
honestly they are a little mixed there
are a handful of and I would say in key
roles very committed performances I
would say mrs. Coulter Lyra Azrael I've
not forgotten the name of lin-manuel
Miranda's character but him as well they
really felt like they got their
characters and were committed to
delivering what needed to be brought
across about themselves most though not
all but most of the other characters
they I didn't get a real sense of
performance about them like and if I got
anything it was real OneNote there
doesn't seem to be a lot of depth in
most of the supporting characters and it
doesn't help that a lot of the dialogue
is really stilted the actors who I named
do a pretty good job of bringing some
life into the characters that they're
portraying but everybody else their
lines no not everybody but nearly
everybody else their lines read really
flat which is weird to me because
normally line readings that flat I would
have thought was because well it's an
exposition line so it's difficult to
deliver except they most of them are
decks position lines cuz there's not off
exposes you for me to even wrap my head
fully around this world and this setting
so that's not really the case but the
line readings are still flat I have to
wonder and I have no way of confirming
this the way that it sounded a lot of
time was like they lifted lines directly
from the book which 9 times out of 10 is
a really bad idea except for any like
specific iconic lines of dialogue the
reason for that is and I'm not sure if
if people properly realize this but
there are things and ways of speaking
that you can get away with on the page
because you don't have to hear a human
being try to speak them
if part of why expositional dialog
doesn't sound as clunky written as it
does on screen that's not to say that it
can't still be done poorly on the page
it can but there isn't as much of a
necessity to have realistic natural
flowing dialogue on the page if a writer
can do it that's great but they don't
have to when they can get away with it
without doing that but once people have
to actually say these words and you have
to hear them said by people that's
supposed to sound like a conversation
and they're they're written in a way
that was designed to work on the page
and suddenly haha quit doesn't work and
again I have no idea if lines were
lifted directly from the books but the
Stilton way in which a lot of the lines
are delivered and written certainly made
it feel to me like that was probably the
case but that's a guess on my part
that's me trying to figure out why I
didn't get into this thing all that much
so my standard grace period for any show
is usually three episodes if I'm three
episodes in and it hasn't hooked me if
it hasn't given me a reason to want to
keep coming back I usually walk so this
thing had one more episode than my usual
grace period and it still didn't really
get me I'll grant that Episode four was
better than the preceding three episodes
but that was really just because of the
president the presence of lin-manuel
Miranda cuz he liven things up a whole
bunch but I'm not sure that's enough to
keep me going like I said I have a hard
time wrapping my head around this world
and a lot of the idiosyncrasies and I
don't know how much of this again is
direct from the book or not but the mix
of the world as I know it and a world
very much not the one I know for me was
poorly balanced because in my mind if
you're going to sew directly evoke the
world I know to the point that you
actually use city names of real cities
of like London and Essex
and you have you know boats that are
recognizable as the style of boats that
like I
would know from the time you know maybe
a little bit run down a little output
but like it's it's a riverboat that
looks familiar I've seen stuff like that
and you know apartments with elevators
and like it all seems very familiar like
of the world I I have then there's only
so much world breaking mythology you can
add into that before it doesn't track
anymore and what I mean by that is this
it probably would have flowed for me if
it was just a case of the demons are
part of this and maybe with the
kidnapped children maybe the thing with
the maybe you know the dust as a lure
but the instant you introduce something
like the Magisterium which is so
powerful that it very clearly shapes and
controls the world at that point that is
such a massive departure structurally
from how the world I know works that I
now have a hard time believing that this
world has so much in parallel with the
one I know that there would still be a
London that they would still have a
similar technology track you know at
least up to a certain point and like the
that is such that something that big
that make a change I'm like well this
can't be the world I know anymore and so
now all the elements that look like
they're listed directly from the world I
know aren't gelling and they feel just
in the incongruous to me and part of
that may actually just be an issue with
the show as opposed to the book because
if the book simply called say the boats
that the Egyptians have which I thought
I don't know what it is about that name
that really like yeah actually you know
what that was one of the things about
the dialogue that really threw me off
they keep they don't have nicknames or
shorten for anything like something when
talking about or even to people people
keeps using their first and last name
like like what the Kostas
they'd say Tony Costa Billy Costa they
never just say Tony like I think the
mother is the only one who says
tonio just Billy everyone else says the
full name every didn't they address
anyone its first and last name every
time I think it's part of why the
dialogue felt so unnatural anyway
hmm moving on from that so like things
like the boats that the Egyptians have
those might be described in the book as
simply being boats which leaves it more
or less to the reader to decide what
they look like but when I see them it's
clear that for the probably for the
purposes of Budget Control the BBC just
grabbed boats that they have I eat real
boats that really exist in this world
and it's the same with a lot of the
exterior shots and the buildings I'm
like that's something that I know and
recognize so it's not otherworldly but
the degree of other worldliness and
again it's not just the demons it's like
the fundamental world and history of
this place with things like the
Magisterium being so different from how
the world I know works i it doesn't gel
it might gel in something a little bit
more irreverent something not taking
itself so seriously something with a
lighter more whimsical feel maybe I
could probably roll with it but this
thing is deathly serious and that
doesn't help either in terms of my
trying to roll with this and the demons
while I said you know they're fine
they're actually kind of not at least as
far as I've gotten into this because I
don't get it like I get the concept like
somebody's soul is an external thing
with the opposing gender that they have
that shifts until they hit puberty then
it solidifies into a form but you know
there's the logistical questions of has
this been the case for all people
forever in the history of time why do I
keep seeing characters usually non
important ones but why do I keep seeing
characters moving around who appear to
have no demons with them whatsoever I
know the real reason they didn't want to
spend the money to CGI up a whole bunch
of demons for characters who didn't
matter but that question comes up for me
and like does the appearance of
someone's demon is that actually a
reflection of
think about them because it feels like
sometimes it's supplying that it is
other times if it's doing that I don't
quite get what the link is why do some
people's demons talk freely why do
others like never speak and maybe
there's answers that come down the line
for this but it's a fundamental factor
of this world and I'm just sitting here
going ah but more importantly than the
logistical questions narrative Lee four
episodes in I don't understand why
Philip Pullman created them so far as
far as their impact on the plot or the
narrative they don't serve a lot of
function they're a gimmick again as far
as I've gotten you could remove them and
really all you would lose is a little
bit of dialogue that some characters
like liar I have with their demons but
that's about it you don't lose much
narrative and plot so for the purposes
of the story being told I don't know why
they exist so I'm left with questions
both narrative and but you know both
narrative storytelling and logistical
which just having both those questions
makes it frustrating and again this
really just feels like it's here for
people who already known so you can
watch and see this world that you've
read brought to life but as someone who
doesn't know this stuff I'm just put off
you know and we've got this whole thing
with other worlds and dust and nobody
even really explains why we have
questions about that I get that dust is
kind of a mysterious thing but I don't
understand why anyone is looking into it
why other people are afraid of it being
looked into it seems to just be well cuz
the Magisterium is scary well that you
could you give me a little bit more than
that cuz again I don't understand the
structure and how this organization
works and how it has the level of
control that it does I just
the one thing that it tried to give me
to latch on to that I liked maybe if it
flowed a little better and other things
fell into place I could have latched on
to in spite of not having an overall
view and feeling like I got this world
is the idea kids kidnapped rescue kids I
that might have been enough except they
didn't they didn't give me rightfully
invested well no I take that back they
did start can be invested in Roger but
it seems like so much of the emphasis on
rescuing is on Billy Costa who is a
character who I don't know aside from
he's kidnapped so like the one visceral
thing the one tangible goal that I get I
don't have enough investment in for that
to override all the hidden goals and
agendas that people have that I don't
know about and I have no investment in
because I don't know what the stakes are
so and also huh I I was off to a rough
start right at the beginning because the
opening text crawl mentions a prophecy
the the degree to which I'm done with
prophecy and chosen one narratives and
that's not saying there are no good ones
I'm just saying I'm sick of them much
like Doctor Who mystery box series arc
stuff you know as a way to connect to
the overall stories of that show I'm
done with them doesn't mean they're
always bad it just means I'm sick of
them same thing with prophecies and
chosen ones and initially it seemed like
it was gonna dodged a bullet because
clearly Lyra is this thing's form of a
chosen one fine but initially it was
grounding what she was doing in much
more tangible things that made immediate
sense her friends missing she wants to
find her friend but then as soon as she
hooks up with Egyptians then all the
chosen one nonsense comes in like oh she
can just magically use the I can't
remember what the heck it's called so
I'm just gonna call it the Golden
Compass forgive me but she can just use
it why because of authorial decree
she's important because the author has
declared her so by means of a prophecy
I'm just I'm just not invested and again
I'm not sure that I'd actually call it
bad
only that from the perspective by which
I came at this thing as somebody with
barely any knowledge about it at all no
I can't get into it and I suspect it's
probably good if you know something more
about the source material or if you're
willing to extend it a slightly longer
leash than I am like I said it's not
completely devoid of oops it's just the
ones that it has offered by by the end
of episode 4 aren't enough for me to
sink more time into it I've got other
stuff to do and I don't really feel like
moving forward with this I have a
feeling a lot of people are gonna be
annoyed with me a lot of people are
gonna tell me how they didn't read the
original but they still got into the
show or that I'm an idiot or you know I
this feels like the kind of thing where
people are gonna think I'm attacking a
fandom and I'm not I don't understand
this thing well enough to attack it on
its fundamentals beyond the use of
prophecy I'll attack it for that because
I'll attack anything for that at this
point but you know I just I'm I'm sorry
I don't get it and maybe that is on me
but that's where I land His Dark
Materials this series have you seen it
what do you think about it you probably
liked it but like looking at getting a
general read on just like viewer reviews
in the IMDB score and things like that
people seem to like it so whatever your
thoughts are on it or whatever reason
you think I'm a [ __ ] for not sticking
with it go ahead and drop it down in the
comments and we'll talk about it as long
as you can be polite don't call me a
[ __ ]
that'd be nice but you know whatever I'm
not gonna tell you what to do plus you
know there's other stuff that you can do
besides just
cuz like subscribe support on patreon
that's how I got commissioned to view
these things in the first place I hope
that they don't want their money back
given my feelings on the thing ah I feel
really bad when I get commissioned for
something and I suspect they wanted me
to enjoy it and I don't but that's it
that's you know that's just the way it
is but you can support me on patreon as
well all the other stuff but you don't
have to do it either cuz end of the day
folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]